for a second day britain and the world
are celebrating queen elizabeth's
amazing 70 years on the throne earlier
this morning a thanksgiving church
service was held at st paul's cathedral
in london the queen was not there
buckingham palace said she had some
discomfort after attending yesterday's
events prince harry and meghan did make
their first appearance of the jubilee
this morning the queen's busy thursday
ended when she lit a ceremonial beacon
last night at windsor castle it's a very
pretty ceremony we're joined now by roy
anika she's the royal editor of the
sunday times in london and she's covered
the royal family for more than a decade
we find her outside of st paul's
cathedral the bells have been very busy
there roya good morning to you hopefully
they'll stay silent no
we hear them right now during the
interview they will not stay silent for
us let's talk about the queen's health
we saw her on the balcony she seemed to
be in good spirits she seemed to be
sturdy and yet she's got discomfort and
we're not seeing her at some events
today how's she doing what do you know
well good morning here from some pools
and those bells are actually going to
ring for another four hours in honor of
her majesty in terms of her health well
look she really put on a brilliant show
yesterday we saw her three times twice
on the buckingham palace balcony then
again in the evening at windsor lighting
that beacon and even then you could see
she did look like she was struggling to
walk but determined to go on with the
show we've heard from buckingham palace
that she's been feeling a bit of
discomfort we know she has these ongoing
mobility issues it has seen prince
charles and prince william stand in for
her on occasions recently
we wish her all while she was much
missed here today but again we're in
this period of transition now and prince
of wales stepped into her again
representing her at st paul's
well it was just so good to see the
queen looking so beautiful and so serene
in her powder blue and this is her first
jubilee without her beloved prince
philip by her side it must be
bittersweet for her at this time and for
the country as well you start reflecting
about what we're missing
i think that's exactly right and you
know the queen has done so many jubilees
now extraordinary historic 70 year reign
but this of course as you mentioned the
first without the longest serving
consult in british history his royal
highness the duke of edinburgh and
there's no doubt you know he is missed
by all the family and i think we will
see references to him uh in celebrations
over the next couple of days we've got
the party at the palace tomorrow night
and he will be remembered there and
again on sunday um so you know she is
she is going through all these
extraordinary big events this four-day
celebration with her family around but
without the the real rock by her side
without prince philip and that must be
incredibly hard for her
i know you know the royal family very
well and for the first time we're seeing
pictures of harry and meghan markle
together this is megan's visit as you
know for the first time since they left
the uk how is she being received she
looks stunning
she absolutely does she looked beautiful
and she was received they both were
received very warmly at the steps of
some halls as they arrived as they went
up the steps they were huge cheers from
the crowd i'm really happy to see them
actually i was watching them very
closely as they came in and they were
received by the clergy and both harry
and megan looked really chatty really
animated like they were really enjoying
themselves and people were very pleased
to see them back they are of course this
is their first big public event here for
almost two years more than two years so
it's a big one
yeah yeah and i know prince andrew they
said reported uh positive for covet is
he all right
we understand yes that he is all right
we don't think he's suffering too much
he was just doing routine tests and of
course he has seen her majesty in the
last few days but not crucially we're
told since he tested positive covered
otherwise he would have been here today
as part of the service
all right roy anika always good to see
you thank you so much